what about who would you consider your
top like four or five like your personal
I don't got to be the greatest of all
time I'm talking about just like your
personal favorites just MC's all time
oh Coogi rap I put at the top of the
list yeah obviously the rest of these
ain't in no order but G Rap started
first you know and yeah you've obviously
got music dedicated to him shout out to
cool G Rap
um [ __ ]
whole
not just from lyrical content from from
from The Fill everything everything [ __ ]
it yeah
um knives for creativity
[ __ ] rewind man like creativity like
I got different Rappers that's for
different things Tupac for emotion pain
yep that was the first person that made
me feel something like how I feel sad or
I feel happy I feel Tupac from Pain
um one more
one more huh
damn
big big and without a doubt big for just
like
flow the best flow ever flow butter flow
right big for flow right period like
that's fair yeah that's a great five
should I call you rap too man don't get
enough flowers out here honorable
mention Big Pun pun man honorable
mentioned capital punishment oh my God
yeah that's one of the biggest the
biggest whatevers I'm like man what a
pun would have never passed man [ __ ]
where would he be at right now I mean
[ __ ] Biggie and Tupac we could say that
about three of them right I don't know
[ __ ] be a whole different landscape of
this whole game bro that's so fun it'd
be insane man